heads about eyes closed
father in heaven we thank you for your
word we thank you for the challenge of
your word
but the challenge though it may seem
great is possible through jesus christ
as christ remained in your love through
obedience
help us to remain in his love through
obedience help us to
understand their god whatever we feel
whatever we're suffering
jesus feels it with it right now where
we sit or stand
give us the god of mind give us a heart
to obey our savior
because we love him now dear god
as we move into questions and answers
grant us wisdom that we may understand
your word
in jesus name we pray let god's people
say
amen and amen what's the first bible
question
go to psalm 119
verse 172 what does that say
my tongue shall speak of thy word come
on four
all thy commandments are righteousness
all right
obedience is righteousness in action
go to romans chapter eight
it really is one of the finest questions
you can ever ask the question he just
do we have romans chapter eight yes
let's read from verse one
read with me yeah there's therefore now
no condemnation to
them who are in christ jesus who walk
not after the flesh
but after the spirit for the law of the
spirit of life in christ jesus
hath made me free from the law of sin
and death now
for what the law could not do in that it
was weak through the flesh
god sending his own son in the likeness
of sinful flesh
and forcing condemned sin in the flesh
finish the verse now
that the righteousness of the law might
be fulfilling
us who walk not after the flesh but
after the spirit
someone walking after the spirit is
walking in righteousness
and righteousness is simply a life in
conformity
with the law of god and the law of god
is most clearly expressed in the ten
commandments and
in the actual life of christ obedience
is righteousness in action
next question
you